hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news
on today's programme the country is
falling behind in the race against
climate
we speak to the cop 26 president taking
the fight to turkey
concerns drought could be the next
global pandemic
and the uk and europe join the race for
gigafactories
building car batteries
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes that are
happening to our world right now
and we meet those coming up with the
solutions and climate change
is a global fight with real worldwide
consequences
the role of cop 26 in glasgow later this
year
is to encourage ambitious government
policies and in its words
accelerate action its president alok
sharma has traveled to turkey to
strengthen support
ahead of the climate conference now
greenhouse gas emissions in
turkey rose by 134 percent between 1990
and 2017 and they're expected
to go up again by between 40 and 70
percent by 2030. that's compared
to today's levels well turkey is taking
action on climate
in the paris agreement it states it's
bringing down carbon emissions to help
in the attempt to limit global warming
but it's described as critically
insufficient according
to climate action tracker and is one of
only
six countries not to have ratified the
deal
earlier i spoke to umet shahin a senior
scholar and the coordinator of
climate change studies at istanbul
policy center
everything turkey is doing to combat
climate changes
about national policies but
unfortunately turkey is not one of the
countries
to accept net zero target yet
2050 net zero targets
and turkey does not have any uh absolute
emissions reduction commitment well i'm
pleased to say that
cop 26 president alok sharma joins
me now mr sharma good to talk to you
when you see these images in turkey you
see an
urgent need to get them on board how
will you persuade them
well i've had a very good set of
discussions with a range of ministers
today
and there is a clear recognition here
that actually climate change is an
issue that affects all countries uh
climate change doesn't recognize borders
and turkey itself of course is a climate
vulnerable country it sits in the
mediterranean
basin which is one of the uh most
climate vulnerable regions in the world
the discussions i've had today have
centered around
how turkey can do even more and while
we're trying to pressure other countries
to do
their bit we need to get our own house
in order don't we a report out this week
says the uk
is woefully unprepared and more so than
five years ago for climate change
well i would say uh we should be judged
on uh what we have achieved
so since the year 2000 we have been the
country of all the g20 nations which has
decarbonized our economy the fastest
uh we're of course the first country to
put into law that we would be net zero
by 2050
and we've also set out a 2030 emission
reduction target
of 68 uh in terms of our emissions
and of course we are taking concrete
action uh at the end of last year
the prime minister put out his uh
10-point plan for a green industrial
revolution
demonstrating how we ourselves are going
to be transitioning to clean energies
and ensuring that we aren't able to meet
the environmental commitments that we
have made
mr sharma i would like to refer to our
data dashboard here which shows that
50 of the power mix is still coming
from fossil fuels when you look at that
you wonder
why are we opening coal mines well uh
if you are referring to uh the proposed
coal mine in in cumbria that of course
has now
gone to public inquiry so we'll see what
happens
as part of that but if you look at the
energy mix of the uk
40 percent of our energy was coming from
our electricity
power was coming from coal uh in 2012
we're now below two percent
and we've said by 2024 no more coal
in our electricity mix that is real
progress and the reason samantha we've
been able to do that
is we have grown our offshore wind
sector to now be the biggest in the
world
the largest offshore wind sector in the
world and we're going to quadruple that
over the next 10 years okay alex sharma
good to talk to you thank you
thank you well let's bring you some more
of the day's climate news now
and more than a quarter of uk schools
are located in areas above
the world health organization air
pollution limits that's according to new
data that's been released by the
campaign group
global action plan it suggests over 3.4
million children are learning
in an unhealthy environment
china has launched a spacecraft carrying
three astronauts
to part of its new space station the
country's first crewed mission
in five years the crew will spend three
months aboard the space station
236 miles above the earth
it comes after nasa criticized china for
failing to take responsibility for their
space debris
which impacts the environment
and an attempt to break the record for
the fastest train journey between
london and glasgow the avanti west coast
service arrived at glasgow central
just 21 seconds behind the current
record
despite not making a new record the
transport secretary grant chaps
says the attempt highlights how trains
are a clean
green way of connecting major cities in
the uk
now i want to bring in our data
dashboard for you here
well this shows the level of human
induced global warming since the
industrial revolution
just over 1.2 degrees and it's ticking
up the whole time
and this is the total amount of global
co2
emissions 2.41 trillion
tons and again it's ticking up even
while we look at it
well those rising temperatures are being
blamed for severe drought which is being
felt
all over the world so what is drought
let's have a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well the un has released a report today
with a warning
that drought could become the next
global pandemic
mommy's is a un special representative
of the secretary general
for disaster risk reduction and joins me
now uh hello mommy how is drought
going to look like the next pandemic so
drought is a disaster which
expands across nations regions
the spatial scale is enormous and the
time scale
it can affect countries for years
if not decades thirdly the cascading
impact beyond the first
water stress the first impact is
is across sectors across
scales and then finally if a drought
happens
in one or two of the major production
areas of the four crops rice wheat
maize and soy at the same time it can
really ignite
a global food insecurity so that's why
we think that
drought could be the next pandemic
a pandemic without a vaccine of course
um
is it affecting more and more countries
absolutely so our report is drawing
um data from ipcc and
uh it says that in all of americas from
north
central to south australia africa
southern europe and central asia there
is
a high risk of severe drought because of
global warming
okay mommy misery really good to talk to
you thank you
thank you now west africa has been
greatly
impacted by drought but now there's a
campaign to plant
around 355 000 trees in 90 villages
across mali and senegal the project is
being
run by the international olympic
committee to offset its climate
emissions it's called the great green
wall initiative
and is in conjunction with the un and
tree aid
which aims to restore degraded
landscapes in
the sahel region in africa
and staying in that region the tree
planting efforts don't stop there we can
take you now
to ethiopia's matema forest
[Music]
trade works in dry land african
countries where
people are living on just on the front
line of the climate crisis areas
[Music]
i can tell you about the reserve because
of the climate change
he has lost some of the fertility of his
land
the rain is not no more reliable so some
of the crops he has been growing
as now not able to be grown and then
able to harvest good things
[Music]
the changing climates made his farming
no more enough to produce for his family
to feed the whole year
poor people living in there if they lose
their
security of producing and living in that
area
then after 20 years that
place will not be able to support
the peoples living around
there were some rivers which have been
flowing
year round we need to have some
support to cross those rivers because
they have water flowing during even dry
season
but nowadays because of this climate
christ those rivers
and streams which are no more there
now we know that one of the best ways to
decarbonize our transport system right
now
is by switching to electric cars in 2018
the uk produced half of all electric
cars in europe
but the expansion of gigafactories on
the continent
means that that could fall to just four
percent by 2030.
now is the uk racing to catch up
gigafactory ultimately is a factory that
produces batteries
or battery cells to be precise at scale
[Music]
it produces at least a gigawatt hour of
those batteries
if you use your dishwasher you would be
using around one
kilowatt hours of electricity and in
this case one gigawatt hour is at least
one million times that
we have seen a number of investments
happening in europe and if they all
scale up on time
in fact by 2030 europe will be producing
one third of the global battery
production capacity
the factories so far announced in the uk
a very small fraction
electric cars can be cheaper as petrol
cars
as soon as 2026 across europe
to make that happen we need to push car
makers
to invest in mass production of those
vehicles
well that is all for today tomorrow sky
news is in south sudan where
entire communities have been devastated
by severe flooding
that's at the same time tomorrow here on
sky news hope to see you then